-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back.
This is our second to last show
in the captain's quarters,
and we're starting to worry
we're just not gonna get to
everything we wanted to get to.
For example, I wanted to do
a whole new book bit
where I would take a book
and replace the "bird"
in the title with "Thorn Birds."
For example,
"To Kill a Mockingbird"
would appear behind me and
then later would mysteriously
change to
"To Kill a Thorn Bird."
I think that would have
been amazing,
but we didn't have time.
I also hoped that, by not
cutting my hair for six months,
it would magically transform
into Steff hair
from "Pretty in Pink,"
but instead it seems to be
trending towards
summertime Steve Bannon.
You know, "Point Broke"
over there.
"Utah, gimme ten!"
But one thing we did promise you
was a B-plot
wherein the Sea Captain
faces off with his nemesis,
a giant ghost lobster.
And since we have never
broken a promise to you,
here it is, for your enjoyment,
that exciting action sequence.
-The time for reckoning
is now!
-Release me, foul beast!
-20 seconds until he drags you
into a watery grave,
Sea Captain!
-Quick, Ira, throw me
that spoon.
-Right away, Sea Captain.
-Steve, give me that weird egg
with the lighthouse on it.
-You got it, Sea Captain.
-Vickie, toss me
that wooden buoy.
-The mermaid's name is Vickie?
-We never established it wasn't.
Oh, hey, that reminds me
of a joke.
-We don't have time for this,
Sea Captain.
-Well, maybe if your stupid
"Closer Looks" weren't so long,
we would have time for it.
-Maybe they wouldn't be so long
if you didn't interrupt
so often.
-Ten seconds, Sea Captain!
-Do you want to hear
the joke or not?
-Fine.
-Okay.
What do you call
a mythical creature
at her best friend's wedding?
-Is it a mermaid of honor?
-No!
Okay, yes, it --
it actually --
You got it.
-♪ Sea Captain! ♪
-Watch "MacGruber" on Peacock.
-Sometime next year.
-And speaking of explosions --
-Segue plug!
-The President --
-Oh, hey, Seth, if we're
plugging stuff,
I have a new podcast.
It's called "Duck and Cover."
Because, you know, I'm a duck
and it covers my take
on world events.
You know, just my musings
and whatnot.
-You're really throwing
the brakes
on the momentum here, Ira.
-Okay, so I can't plug
my projects.
Okay, that's really helpful
to know. Thank you.
-What can I say?
I'm gonna miss these guys.
The President and Fox News are
desperately trying to distract
from the Democratic National
Convention.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Donald Trump has been trying to
counter-program the DNC
with his own campaign events.
And look, whatever you want
to say about Trump --
like he's an incompetent,
grifting,
sociopathic golf ogre --
at least he's also
a terrible campaigner.
He's been trying to win over
voters he condescendingly
refers to as
"suburban housewives,"
with some bald-faced
racism,
and in Wisconsin on Monday,
he took another shot
at wooing that key voting bloc
by continuing to insult them.
-But this is the future that
Joe Biden plans to bring
to every city, town,
and suburb in our nation.
And, you know,
for those suburbs,
I keep hearing about
suburban women.
I made the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh.
[ Cheering continues ]
Well, you know,
in one speech recently,
I called you
suburban housewives,
and they all loved it,
but what I got, they said,
"Sir, I don't know if that's
politically correct."
I said, "Don't worry about it,
They'll get over it." Right?
-He's a political
mastermind, folks.
Some people still think
he's playing
three-dimensional chess,
but I think he's playing
"Chutes and Ladders,"
all-chutes addition.
I hope the Trump campaign
is already printing up
their new lawn signs,
"Trump 2020 --
You'll Get Over it."
It's amazing, he even insults
voters he's trying to win over.
He can't help himself.
[ As Trump ] "And what's up
with Evangelicals?
Are these guys weird or what?
I mean, if Jesus is hiding
inside that little cracker,
why would they eat --
Don't eat Jesus.
Don't worry. Don't worry.
They'll get over it."
And then Trump whined that,
because he was investigated
for Russian collusion,
he -- he -- should get
a third term.
-We are going to win the state
of Wisconsin,
and we are going
to win four more years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Crowd chanting
"Four More Years" ]
-And then after that, we'll go
for another four years
because -- you know what,
they spied on campaign,
we should get a redo
of four years.
-You're still on that?
Man, when it comes
to getting over it,
he is no suburban housewife.
And even when he's pretending
to be a politician,
he can't shake
his loan shark DNA.
"The interest is 100 percent,
but let's make it 200 percent,
'cause I saw you lookin' at my
girlfriend, how 'bout that?"
The only redo anyone
is getting is us
listening to you bitch about
an election you won.
But yeah, I'm sure he'll be
laid-back and cool if he loses.
"I may be a terrible winner,
Joe,
but I'm an exceptional loser.
Congratulations,
President Biden."
In fact, a day after Trump
whined about the Russia probe,
we got definitive evidence
that his campaign did
collude with Russian
intelligence --
from a Republican-led --
a Republican-led --
Senate intelligence committee.
-A newly released Senate report,
Natalie,
raising more red flags about
the relationship
between the 2016
Trump campaign and Russia.
According to the Senate
intelligence committee,
former campaign chairman
Paul Manafort
employed a Russian
intelligence officer
named Konstantin Kilimnik.
and briefed Kilimnik
on the campaign's strategy
for beating Hillary Clinton.
The report also says Manafort
might have had a connection
to Russian
hack-and-leak operations.
-That's right, the Russian
investigation is back, baby!
Remember that whole plot line
from a few seasons ago
when we all got to know
and love crazy characters
like Paul Manafort,
Felix Sater,
Konstantin Kilimnik,
George Papadopoulos,
and Sam Clovis?
You remember --
"Hogan's Zeroes."
Well, they're back in the news
now that the Senate
Intelligence Committee
has released the final volume
of its Russia report
with the shocking finding
that Trump campaign manager
Paul Manafort shared internal
campaign polling data
with a Russian
intelligence officer
who may have well been involved
in the hacking.
This is as definitive
as it gets.
Collusion happened.
And the worst part is, no one
cares because it's old news.
It's like finding out now
that the characters on "Lost"
really did die
in the plane crash.
"Huh. So the island was
purgatory?
Okay."
Also, I just want to say to
the Senate and Robert Mueller
and everyone --
everyone else involved
in the Russia investigation,
way to slow walk it, fellas.
You couldn't have released
definitive proof
of a criminal conspiracy
to cheat in the 2016 election
before Trump botched
a deadly pandemic
that left the nation in ruins?
I can't wait until August 2022
when the Senate announces
that yes, Trump did burn all the
mail-in ballots from blue states
the day before the election.
Trump cheated in 2016 just like
he's trying to cheat now --
this time, by trying to
subvert mail-in voting
and sow chaos and confusion.
Once again, for example,
he repeated a bunch of
insane lies about non-existent
voter fraud.
-If you go with this
universal mail-in,
where you send millions
of votes --
in California, tens of millions
of ballots being sent
to everybody and their dogs.
Okay?
Dogs are getting them, okay?
People that have been dead for
25 years are getting them.
You have to see what's
happening.
Then you're never going to have
a fair election.
-Right.
-I'll say this,
you're never going to have
a fair election.
-"And it's worse than you
think, people,
because one dog vote,
I don't have to tell you,
counts as much as seven
human votes."
Also, you're complaining about
people who have been dead
for 25 years getting ballots?
Look, I don't like him
either,
but Rudy has just as much of
a right to vote as anyone else.
"I vote for more soup!"
And does he really think dogs
are getting ballots?
Like, how does he think
that works?
Like, you'd get an envelope
at your house
from your local board of
elections addressed to Rusty,
and you'd go inside
and you say,
"Rusty, Rusty,
buddy, you got some mail,"
then he'd come over and just
put it in his mouth.
Then he would take it
into the kitchen,
sit down, grab a pen,
fill it out,
stamp it with his paw,
then he would put it back
in the mail, I guess,
and then it gets
to the country registrar,
and they take a look at it,
and they check Rusty's name
to, you know,
the name and the registration,
and they say,
"Oh, it looks good to me."
And then Rusty
gets on the phone
and calls Joe Biden
and says "It's done,"
and then Joe Biden says,
"Good boy."
Just as it was in 2016,
Trump's strategy in 2020
is not to win the most votes
but to cheat.
Democrats meanwhile
have been focussed
on their own convention.
There have been some memorable
moments, from Bernie's speech
in front of the National
Strategic Firewood Reserve
to Michelle Obama's
powerful address,
to the guy from Rhode Island
apparently holding
a plate of calamari hostage.
"Give us the money or you'll
never see this plate
of fried squid again."
Although I have to ask,
what was the obsessive focus
on Republicans about?
I mean, who cares what
Meg Whitman
and John Kasich think?
You do know they can't
even get Republicans
to listen to them, right?
Kasich's speech looked like a
commercial for TD Ameritrade.
"Down this path
is a path is a lifetime of debt.
Down this path is
a secure retirement."
Outside of that, the convention
has featured inspiring stories
of activists,
everyday Americans,
essential workers, and some of
the party's most talented
rising stars, so Fox News
was desperate
to counter-program it.
Here's what Sean Hannity told
his viewers last night.
-It was boring, it was
awkward, it was disjointed.
All you got was a temper
tantrum, bumper sticker slogans
about pretty much how much
they hate Donald Trump,
and behind the hatred of him
is a hatred
of we smelly Walmart shopper
Trump supporters.
-Oh, "we," Sean?
So you're one of the so-called
"smelly Walmart shoppers"?
When you're done with your
million-dollar
cable news network gig
in Manhattan,
I'm sure you're swinging by
the local Walmart to pick up
some grass seed and hair wax,
maybe some Kyle Busch pajamas
for the kids, please.
If your driver accidentally
went by a Walmart,
you'd be screaming to him
to lock the doors.
Also, no one called them that.
You called them that.
If anything, you just revealed
what you think
of Trump supporters.
"Smelly, Walmart-shopping
Trump supporters.
And I mean, Trump supporters
just stink, am I right?
They're rank, probably because
they're stupid.
If you gave a Trump supporter
a bar of soap,
they'd cut it in half
and put it on your toast.
Ha ha!
Smelly, stupid Trump supporters.
That's us, right, guys?"
These guys are such cheesy
scam artists.
Their whole schtick is
pretending to be
everyman populists
when in reality they're trying
to use you as canon fodder
to rev up the economy
while they sit safely ensconced
in the White House
or their studios with their
million dollar contracts.
Meanwhile, their guy
is trailing badly in the polls,
and if he loses will just
have to tell him to...
-They'll get over it, right?
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
-Now more than ever,
City Harvest needs your help
feeding New York families
hit by the COVID crisis.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
Wear a mask. We love you.